un mouton de la reine un cochon en super
héros une vache coquette où un homme
amoureux
ce sont les animaux de la ferme pour
constituer le hameau du trianon palace
de versailles
des sculptures en chocolat imaginé à
l'occasion des fêtes de pâques par le
chef pâtissier eddie benghanem les
animaux de la ferme sur un visuel très
ludique très sympa c'était en fait je me
suis inspiré surtout des doudous ont des
doudounes et fille en fait et je voulais
retranscrire à travers ces sujets
quelque chose de mignon généreux
gourmand et en même temps très
versailles à qui l'animal est composé
d'une boule pour le corps du notebook
pour la tête
ou alors d'un oeuf pour la tête même
volume même taille même forme même
auteur en chocolat blanc noir ou au lait
les animaux sont colorés avec du beurre
de cacao
une première couche de peinture de bloc
azero colorés pour avoir un aspect
uniforme
ensuite une deuxième couche de peinture
quand le fus est soit un petit peu plus
froid on aura un aspect légèrement
vanité une fois la coloration terminée
place au collage chaque animal est fixé
à un coeur sur une boîte en chocolat
noir rempli de praliné on va chauffer le
coeur est en fait le mouton va venir se
coller directement et va prendre la
forme fourni du coeur et basculer
automatiquement
l'an prochain le chef eddie benghanem
pense déjà à compléter sa collection
avec une poules et un coq en attendant
ces animaux vont sûrement se cacher dans
le jardin du trianon palace pour les
fêtes de pâques